and as you get ready for thanksgiving in
the holidays it's a good idea to
implement a recycling plan too
jeremy walters from republic services
joining us to share
some of the tips the environment will be
thankful for
it's holiday season again and everyone's
wondering you know
how they're going to recycle after
thanksgiving
because we've got lots of cans we've got
lots of plastic leftovers
yeah definitely and you know between
thanksgiving and then all the way
through new year's day we actually see
about a
25 increase in the amount of waste that
people make but the good thing is is
that
a lot of it can be recycled so there are
things that are good for recycling
and not so good things and so we'll kind
of run through those today
okay let's break it down let's start
with the recyclables
all right so with recyclables especially
around thanksgiving some of these items
may seem very familiar so
you've got baking tins number one these
are fine for recycling so long as
they're rinsed clean you know there
can't be residual pie
or turkey or anything like that in them
but they are okay for recycling once you
practice what we call empty clean dry
that same principle holds true with
uh you know pumpkin cans cranberry sauce
soda cans glass bottles those things are
all great for recycling but they do have
to be rinsed clean because there are
fragile items in your recycling bin
such as paper and cardboard those are
great for recycling as well but if they
get soiled with food or liquid we have
to throw them away
so on the topic of paper and cardboard
these things are great for recycling too
but the bag itself can't go in there you
know the
plastic sort of flimsy bags those things
actually wrap and tangle around the
sorting equipment and so you'll see i
have some items over here
that are non-recyclable and one of those
is
the plastic grocery bag right wow yep
exactly those yeah lots of these so
they're
they're
great to reuse around the house you can
use them for small trash can liners
um you know pick up after the animals
things like that or
most of the bags themselves actually say
store drop off only so they can't go in
the recycling bin
if the grocery store you shop at offers
paper bags
paper bags are okay for recycling but
one step further
bring your own bags reusable bags are
great i think on average they save about
20
000 plastic bags in their lifetime think
about sustainability even before your
leftovers go bad right
so you've got typically two ways of
saving your leftovers and one is
you know the ziploc bag oh yeah the
sustainable alternative
is a tupperware tupperware are great
because
you know you can use them over and over
you can wash them you can easily send
them to go with people
ziploc bags and other plastic baggies
same principle as the grocery bags they
can't go in the recycling bin so if
you're trying to be sustainably
conscious throughout the holiday season
think about things like this
reuse is always even better than
recycling so
just think about those as you go through
the holiday season
for more information check out
recyclingsimplify.com
we'll be right back